The answer to this question is yes,
or at least that team structure can matter.
A very interesting study at Microsoft looked how teams that were responsible
for individual features were compose.
More specifically, the study would look for how distant
the common manager of a team was.
If there would be one direct common manager for all members of the team,
that distance would be 1, and if their common manager would be, say,
two levels removed, then the distance would be 2.
If the lowest common manager of a team would be say, Steve Ballmer,
the manager of Microsoft, then the distance would be 7 or 8 or whatever
the number of management levels at Microsoft is.
Now, it turned out that the higher this distance was the more defect prone
the modules produced by that team were.
The assumption is that if there is no joint management in a team
where every decision first has to go up to the highest level and then back again,
then this makes teamwork particularly hard.
It also makes it hard to make decisions,
and it makes it hard to create some common responsibility
for the module you're working on.
This study was made on Windows Vista.
As a result of that study, Microsoft reorganized the teams
for later versions of Windows such that situations like these would no longer occur.